Joe the Joe Thornton Community Center in Saint
Thomas it's the third preseason game for both the
Leafs and the Sabers Buffalo winning its first two
Toronto looking for its first preseason victory
unable to take that pass and work back out
Payton Krebs can't handle it here's Gregor
who's got some giddy up and a shot stopped by
lucidan McGregor had a good start he takes a
high stick here and Lillard moved up but unable
to get that pass cleanly klingberg finds domey
and Domi from the outside with a shot
that sticks to Lucan got new weapons out
there you've got a couple of new looks and each
exhibition game gives you a different type of a
setup Lafferty shot he'll Flex up off the end
glass down for nice at the line Timmons scores
Connor Timmons breaks the ice this one looks like
it got a little tip of maybe John Tavares getting
a piece of it look at the reaction of Lucan and
he doesn't get this one cleanly he's expecting
it coming right to his blocker and looks behind
him and that one pops up and over thanks Christy
and we are looking forward to the all-star game in
Toronto there's a chance in tight for the captain
and Tamara stopped by looking at Irvington over
the line that's broken up by cousins and he takes
the pass from ruseck and a shot wide of the net
team off the inboards and nearly provided cousins
with another chance Dylan cousins the Workhorse
from White Horse in Yukon kept him by oluerson
cousins along the board moving up Davies
scores so a defensive score who scores for
Buffalo Jeremy Davies who has never scored
it NHL goal has won here in the preseason
all the former All-American from Northeastern
does a great job of jumping into the hole and
the best thing you can account for as an 18 year
old coming into camp and both those players have
done it beautifully Ryan Johnson shot from the
point sticks to Martin Jones McCabe headbands
Alex Steves over the line here's Steve swinging
wide Lucan and will flag that down and hold on
power play done for the Maple Leafs they had
two shots on that power play Oh for two here's
Tavares flipping it through and that goes wider
than it got the Sabers 14-4 in the first period
here's a loose Puck that slides just wider than
that and it'll come back to the line and for the
tap in there's a turnover ghost gives it away
here's Gregor trying to speed in and let to the
midsection oh look at him the lead break back in
here's Mitten with Dolby and Mitten the shot has
told me the give and go with power Yuki how are
you oh and power will shoot and a good stop there
by Martin Jones here's the little give and go a
turnover now you got your head up and give and go
down and get yourself open up Minton would stick
on the ice ready to get a quick shot away and that
one easily handled but here is powers on the side
tip in there and just an excellent read by Martin
Jones over the line with knives in the middle
Robertson can't pull the trigger and now fires
high with Holmberg crashing into the net instead
a good defensive play and then coming back there's
the one clutch Robertson couldn't get the handle
on it the first time and you might Force Sheldon
Keith to have an easier decision here's Albert
Jansen that just rolled wide there's Tavares
setting it across that's turned over Dylan
cousins in and Jones with a stop this kind
of neutral zone turnover this is what happens
opens up the ice here cousins got his head up
the entire way but watch the positioning of Jones
he's in good position outside about a foot and a
half from his blue paint listen I played with
Wayne Gretzky and Mario lemieu and they killed
penalties at times so I don't think it's a stretch
to think you want to get him a nice time you just
have to manage it as the games go along here's
a break short-handed nice to [Applause] [Music]
well just as you talk about skilled
players and what they can do on a
penalty kill here's a couple of skilled
plays at high speed Lucas ruschett passes
[Applause] as Jessica passed off from right in
front and now bricklay coming from the box scores
brief score short-handed and then out of the
blocks and Max Domi makes it 3-1 boy isn't
that the game though how quickly it can change
it looks like you're going to have a chance to
tie this game and pissakoff off of a beautiful
pass he just Taps this one in he's got a easy
goal instead he overpasses and then now the
Buffalo Sabers dead at the end of that power
play get caught watching and Domi right
out of the box what a perfect pass look
at him with the stop there off Alex Steves
comes back to LA Joie Max Ling Schwab and
that'll be absorbed by huko pekko looking but
even despite a career year of 28 goals for him
he was a healthy scratch seven times and it's
a play in the defensive Zone that's been the
problem Yoki how are you from the point puts one
true couple of goals by safer defenseman and it's
3-2 Ryan there's what Donnie Granado's been
trying to see the plays made down low winning
a battle now you get Yoki Haru who just came on
and look at the bodies in front of Jones there
and it's been awesome to be here
for this craft hockeyville game a
chance right in front and off the post Nick
Robertson with Michael Hauser in goal and
tested 10 seconds in feeds Bryson and Johnson
shot right on Jones with the stop Martin Jones
with face nine shots through the first
two periods alizo shooting buffalo 14-4
in the first 14-5 and Kyle flipper has one
for error and beliefs that is 4-2 Toronto
Clifford with the Finish now is Tavares
dropping it off Connor Timmins again
nice parked in front back for Lillard Robertson
steered it in front to nice redirects that wide
shooting right on Cowan looks for the rebound
past midst and leaves will counter in 45 leading
the attack again and nice with a shot that glances
off the Blocker of Hauser Robertson doesn't clear
kept in by power gets it back from cousins whoops
across great pass and out comes Jones to cut off
the angle and make a tough stop on bruschak Murray
back to the line Johnson shot and Jones fights
that off and Steve he's and Hauser going to the
bench for an extra attacker Buffalo looking for
one to get within one and domi's gonna flip that
high Minton drew the second assist on the goal in
the third period by Clifford Tim and zacrosse
Cowan back to Timmins and he's got another
half of the night oh you see Holmberg say
that Timmins there Tim and said to tip that
he goes nope Cowan with a puck in his own
Zone and the Maple Leafs have their first
win of the preseason now 1-1-1 in the fans
here in Saint Thomas like the end result
uh you love to hear the reaction of the
fans it's been a great two days with West
Lauren and here in St Thomas and both these
teams worked hard and gave him a great show
that's been a fun visit here to St Thomas
our congratulations again to West Lauren
and the Maple Leafs celebrate the big
preseason performance by Connor Timmons
who finishes with a pair of goals and two
assists and really dominant all night long